. Lovers to friends. Wird die Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt der Welt auch dabei. Und heute auch mal mit dabei. Wir begrüßen Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Jan Delay, weil wir eine kleine Verzögerung haben, deswegen Delay nennt man das, kleiner Gag am Anfang. Immer gut, tatsächlich den Podcast mit einem kleinen Gag anzufangen. Ja, wir haben ein bisschen Aufholarbeit zu tun, denn die letzte Folge war scheiße, die war nicht gut. Wir haben viel Rüge bekommen, viele Beschwerden tatsächlich, Leute haben sich über verschiedene Elemente des Podcasts und über den Podcast im Allgemeinen beschwert. Von daher, glaube ich, haben wir das komplett aufgeschlüsselt. Ja, dafür muss man aber sagen, das Warm-up zu diesem Podcast war schon sehr gut. Es war so gut, dass wir hätten einen nicht aufnehmen sollen lieber, aber leider hat Flo und Tim wieder wie alle drei Wochen pünktlich wieder technische Störungen bekommen. Man weiß nicht genau warum, weil er nie was an dem Set verändert, dass er sich aufgebaut hat. Aber okay, er hat es wirklich ja geschafft, sich was Neues auszudenken. Dafür lieben wir dich. Und ich habe tatsächlich auch ein relativ gutes Setup, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, qualitativ, aber es funktioniert einfach irgendwas. Ich hatte heute zum Beispiel eine Zeit lang einfach zwei Cursor auf meinem MacBook Pro. Einfach zwei Cursor hatte ich die ganze Zeit. Das ist wie in so einem Fussballspiel, wenn jemand einen zweiten Ball reinwirft und dann einfach mal drei Minuten Euphorie und dann erstmal Ernüchterung ist. So war das bei mir heute auch. Wobei ich mir gedacht habe, ist das vielleicht die Zukunft der Informationstechnik? Zwei Cursor pro Rechner mit zwei Mäusen kann man sich noch nie viel besser durch die Tweets und Twins und Teenager klicken. Deswegen frage ich mich ja auch, warum Menschen nicht einfach zwei Bildschirme miteinander aufbauen, lernen, ihre Augen nicht parallel zu bewegen, sondern für sich individuell jedes Auge. Das heißt, man kann auf zwei Rechner parallel arbeiten, man muss halt nur lernen, mit einer Hand zu tippen jeweils und mit zwei Augen verschieden zu gucken, aber dann kann man parallel die doppelte Arbeitsleistung machen. Vielleicht auch noch die Gehirnhälften einfach trennen, die Gehirnhälften trennen, dass man links sich auf etwas anderes konzentrieren kann als rechts, das geht. Ja, oder man engagiert sich in Assistenten und ist einfach zu zweit und Teamwork. Sehr gut, was sind noch die Themen eigentlich? Wir haben heute immer bessere Themen, muss ich auch. Wir haben heute eine neue Unternehmensstruktur, muss ich kurz vorstellen. Wir haben ein knallhartes Textdokument, das uns jede Woche jetzt neu vorschreibt. Wir brauchen ein gutes Thema und wir brauchen eine gute Rubrik, dass wir halt immer irgendwie was haben, woran wir uns entlanghangeln können, weil sonst letzte Woche, das tut uns wahnsinnig leid. Es tut mir auch, ich habe mich geschämt, wirklich. Und wir gehen auch tatsächlich davon aus, dass es ausreichen würde, einfach in fett gedruckter Schrift auf dem Textdokument gute Themen nächstes Mal zu schreiben, damit wir tatsächlich gute Themen haben. Wir wissen ehrlich gesagt noch nicht genau, welche Themen es werden. Schaut einfach in die Podcast-Beschreibung, da steht es dann tatsächlich, wie es am Ende wird. Ich habe ein paar schlechte Gags vorbereitet, die ich vielleicht hier und da ein bisschen unterbringen würde. Aber an sich, es ist ja viel passiert, es wird immer heißer, der Sommer kommt, die Röcke werden kürzer, die Häute werden bräuner. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo diese Hinleitung, die du gerade anfängst, hingeht. Es zeichnet auch so ein bisschen den Podcast aus. Ich habe keinen Plan, was du gerade machst. Aber okay. Man geht wieder mehr raus, man geht raus, man legt sich in die Sonne, man ist wieder ein bisschen im Alltag. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich so, ich verlasse ja kaum mein Haus. Aber mein Fenster ist so gelegen, dass ich ungefähr für eine Stunde pro Tag Sonnenlicht habe. Und zwar ziemlich stark und ich kann mich in meinem Zimmer sonnen. Das ist wirklich kein Witz. Ich kann in meinem Bett liegen und mich eine Stunde lang sonnen, ja. Und letztens dachte ich mir einfach mal fuck it, was soll's, ich werfe mich jetzt einfach dem Körperkult der westlichen Sivilisation unter und habe einfach mal in meinem Zimmer nackt gesonnt. Ich lag einfach fett und schmitzend in meinem Bürosessel direkt vorm Fenster und habe mich gesonnt Ohne zu merken, habe ich dann tatsächlich erst später gemerkt, dass die gegenüberliegende Häuserfassade einfach knallhart in mein Fenster hätte schauen können und mich fett und schwitzend dort hätte liegen sehen können, es wahrscheinlich auch getan hat. Das heißt, achtet mal ein bisschen auf Twitter jetzt tatsächlich, welche Fotos da so hochgeladen werden und macht euch auf eine Überraschung gefasst. Du bist Personens öffentlichen Leben, das kannst du nicht machen. Du kannst drei Dinge nicht machen. Du darfst nicht öffentlich jemanden umbringen, du darfst nicht öffentlich sagen, dass du Nazi bist und du darfst nicht öffentlich dich nackt hinlegen. Und du hast eins der drei Dinge jetzt schon getan. Ja, es ist ja nicht öffentlich. Es ist ja nicht öffentlich. Es ist in meinem eigenen Zimmer, es ist nur die Sonne ist öffentlich. Ich nehme jetzt übrigens Vitamin D. Mir wurde gesagt, dass ich einen Vitamin-D-Mangel habe, hat tatsächlich mein Arzt bescheinigt, weil ich halt nicht an die Sonne komme, weil ich immer noch in diesem beknackten Raum sitze jeden Tag und mir Sachen ausdenke oder meistens klappt es doch nichtmals und dann sitze ich da halt den ganzen Tag und dann bin ich halt nicht in der Sonne. Findest du gut, dass dein Arzt bei deinen 17 Jahren schon aufgegeben hat, dass du jemals wieder an die Sonne gehen wirst, und einfach gesagt hat, nehmen sie einen Finger von dir mit. Komm nicht jeden Tag hierher. Kommt da rein mit seiner Skimaske, und ich meine, was soll man da machen? Jetzt habe ich jeden Tag jetzt Vitamin D, weil das halt so ein Ding ist, also der Körper braucht Sonnenlicht, und dann werden auch das Vitamin D ist auch so ein bisschen, es wird auch Leute, die Depression haben, bekommen Vitamin D, einfach weil man die Befindlichkeit steigert. Und deswegen, ich hatte ja vorher schon keine Depression, ich bin jetzt doppelt glücklich. Ich bin so ein senil, grinsender Typ, der neuerdings geworden ist. Der in seinem Keller in der Dunkelheit sitzt, aber total glücklich ist. Ich bin der glücklichste Mensch der Welt, ich freue mich jeden Tag aufs Neue, auf den Tag und ich beginne den Tag singend. Das ist toll, auf eine Art. Also Vitamin D kann ich jedem empfehlen. Aber ist es nicht so, dass Vitamin D nur Menschen und Hamster brauchen, dass es so eine ganz spezielle Sache von Menschen ist, dass man durch Sonnenlicht Vitamine erzeugt und dass es nur zwei Arten auf der ganzen Welt haben, Menschen und Hamster, kann auch falsch sein. Ja, man weiss es nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist es das. Man weiss es mal wieder nicht. Naja. Ja, ich habe mir Conflicts aus Amerika bestellt und da steht bei den Packungen auch drauf, Great Sauce for Vitamin D. Wobei, das Amerikanische ist ja wesentlich versauter als das Deutsche. Da steht ja Vitamin D auch eigentlich für Vitamin Dick. Also wenn in einem Flirtgespräch eine Frau sagen würde, I'm lacking Vitamin D, dann ist es eine direkte Einladung, den D-Move, den Dick-Move direkt zu präsentieren. Ach so. Ist in Deutschland nicht so, da gibt es nicht so diese klassischen. Vor allem dann nicht, warum nicht auf dem Vitamin D, dann ist es eine direkte Einladung, den D-Move, den Dick-Move direkt zu präsentieren. Ist in Deutschland nicht so, da gibt es nicht so diese klassischen... Aber ich verstehe vor allem dann nicht, warum nicht auf den Vitamin-D-Tabletten-Packungen draufsteht, Great Source for Vitamin D, weil das wäre doch eigentlich ein Grund. Oder vielleicht sogar Best Source. Man könnte vielleicht sich sogar so eine ganz bescheidene Marketingabteilung, die sagt, it's okay, it's an okay source for vitamin D. Die einfach nicht übertreibt. Almost best source for vitamin D. 50% vitamin D. Ding! Was ist der Rest? Findet es raus. No, it's all vitamin D. Don't worry. Kleingedrückt runter wie so ein Sternchen. Just kidding, just kidding. Aber ist es dein Hobby geworden, dich mittlerweile in die Sonne zu legen für eine Stunde?
Hat sich so ein Ritalin eingestiegen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Hobby ist.
Ich würde es jetzt eher unter Kategorie Lifestyle verbuchen, auf der Lifestyle-Seite verbuchen,
das zu meinem ausgeprägten Lifestyle wird.
Ich bin ein Sunnyboy, ich gehöre einfach an die Sonne, ich habe einfach immer das Surfbrett unterm Arm,
was ich tatsächlich auch mal schön machen würde, einfach so in Bermuda-Shorts und irgendwie Badehose und Badekappe und Badebrille mit einem Surfbrett durch Berlin zu stolzieren, wo sich jeder fragt, wo geht der hin? Aber einfach so, ja, irgendwie Beach Boys trellernd einfach mal in der U-Bahn sind, so, I've been looking for, nee, ist nicht, fuck it, ich kann, ich passe einfach nicht in diese Welt. Ich kann keine zwei Minuten aufrechterhalten, dass ich ein cooler Typ bin. Nee, aber es ist ja trotzdem mal cool, mit so einem anderen Outfit, was man in Berlin noch nicht erwartet. Einfach mal mit so einem Strahlenschutzanzug durch Berlin zu laufen. Ja, so Coast Guard einfach, so Bademeister-mäßig. Ja, das ist cool. Das gibt es auch nur in Amerika mit diesen Bojen bei Baywatch, dass sie dann diese roten Bojenjen haben. Ich auch nicht ganz verstehe, was ist denn die Funktion dessen? Nein, ich glaube, wenn Leute kurz vor dem Ertrinken sind, das ist ja immer das Problem, wenn du einen Ertrinkenden rettest, dann kann es ja sein, dass der dich mit in die Tiefe zieht, weil er Panik hat und den Bademeister mit erkennt. Dabei hilft der dann so eine Boje? Nee, deswegen haben die diese Boje, dass sie den im Notfall einfach K.O. schlagen können, dass sie dann irgendwie den besser abtransportieren können. Dass der keine Panik hat, weil der dreht ja komplett durch. Wenn du ertrinkst, dann greifen ja alle Instinkte ein. Ich glaube rot, deswegen sind die auch rot, weil rot ist so eine wahnsinnig beruhigende Farbe auch. Genau, ja. Und die schlagen jetzt dann mehrmals ins Gesicht, sodass du einfach ein bisschen runterkommst und irgendwie ein bisschen mehr chillst und dann ist angenehme Wasser und die Salzwasser. Du bist eher so ein Salzwasser-Typ, ne, habe Gefühl. Auf jeden Fall. Also du könntest in so einem Badesee, bist du auch gar nicht zu Hause, habe ich das Gefühl. Nee, ich war oft in meiner Kindheit, eigentlich jeden Sommer war ich in der Ostsee. Ich habe sehr lange Zeit meiner Sommer immer in der Ostsee verbracht. Sehr toll da. Da gibt es aber, da gibt es den DLRG und die haben aber sowas nicht. Und da fand ich es immer schon interessant, wenn mal eine Flagge raus war oder zwei Flaggen, dann durfte man nicht mehr baden und eine Flagge, dann war halt so ein leichter Wellengang. Und dann sind die manchmal auch mit so einem Bootrohr ausgefahren und haben die Leute ertrinkender gerettet, aber halt nie mit diesen Bojen und auch nie so richtig, richtig geil, dass man denkt, wow, da sind die Coastguards, yeah, und Leute, der ganze Strand steht auf und applaudiert, so war das halt nie, die haben nie so eine Schode rausgemacht, die waren dann immer so, ja, DLRG, ganz geil, dass die sich freiwillig dahinsetzen und so. Würde ich nicht machen.
Ich wurde tatsächlich schon mal aus einem Pool gerettet.
Tatsächlich ist der Badewasser... Aus der Badewanne wurde es gerettet.
Aus der Badewanne gerettet, ja.
Nee, da habe ich tatsächlich mit meinem Onkel, habe ich tatsächlich im Spiel, habe ich mich totgestellt im Wasser und mein Onkel sollte mich dann retten.
Und ich habe das anscheinend so überzeugend gemacht und war irgendwie achteinhalb Minuten unter Wasser, sodass der Bademeister tatsächlich eingeschritten ist und mich da rausgezerrt hat. Und dann ging es dann plötzlich wieder gut und ich in der Erklärsituation war so, no, it's on you, das war irgendwie in Italien oder so. Und ich, no, it's just a joke, I'm not dead, sorry, sorry. Und du plötzlich in Deutschland angefangen hast, irgendwie Italienisch zu reden, fliessend. Genau, nome pecca grande, una cenato fragola. Was ist da unten passiert? Was ist da unten passiert, Florianin? Warum sprichst du eine andere Sprache? Ja, genau. Aber das ist auch scheiße als Bademeister. Weißt du, 99,9% deines Tages besteht daraus, irgendwie Mayonnaise mit Fritten zu essen. Und die letzten 0,1%, wo du dann tatsächlich mal ins Wasser springen wirst, dann ist das so ein fettes Kind, das nicht mal gerettet werden muss. Dann ist es auch das Gegenteil von so einem Heldenauftritt. Hilfe ist ja auch so eine Sache. Ich finde es einen geilen Move von einem Bademeister zu sagen, nee, ich habe gerade gegessen, ich kann nicht erst in einer halben Stunde. Kinder, man darf erst nach einer halben Stunde, nachdem man gegessen hat. Man muss ja auch als gutes Vorbild vorangehen. Ja, eben. Ich kann dich jetzt nicht retten. Und der ganze Stand, ja, da hat er recht. Ich habe keine Badehose an, also kann ich auch nicht in den Pool, ich habe eine Badehose vergessen, also ist nichts. So aus einer Rettungsaktion, wo wirklich Todesangst herrscht, wenn wir mal so eine Lektion draus machen. Das sind auch diese pädagogisch wertvollen Messages, wo auch keiner genau wirklich weiss, was es ist. Ich weiss nicht, ob du diese klassische Kindererziehung-Methode kennst, wo man so diese Botschaft, dass man irgendwie so eine Zahnpastatube hat und einem Kind die Zahnpastatube geht und sagt, hier, drück die mal komplett leer aus, drück die mal auf einen kompletten Tisch. Und dann macht das Kind das und freut sich, dass es irgendwie Schabernack machen kann und dann sagt man, so und jetzt tu die Zahnpasta wieder in die Tube. Und dann das Kind versucht es und kriegt es nicht hin und dann sagt man, ja, siehste mal. Und die Lehre davon ist, manche Dinge sind schwerer, wieder rückgängig zu machen, als sie zu machen. Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Wo ich mir auch jedes Mal gedacht habe, dass das Kind so, what, was? Habe ich noch nie gehört. Doch, klar, ich habe viel mit Kindern gearbeitet. Du kannst dich doch klar sagen, bei etwas, was ich noch definitiv noch nie gehört habe. Ja, aber ich weiß, dass es in der pädagogischen Kinderbetreuung eingesetzt wird und ich dachte mir schon damals einfach, ob das siebeneinhalbjährige Mädchen das jetzt wirklich gerafft hat, was davon die Botschaft sein soll. Ich bezweifle es stark. Bei diesem Zahnding, das ist auch echt ein bisschen windig. Also ich fand immer das sehr merkwürdig. Dann kamen manchmal so Zahnärzte zu uns in die Schule und haben uns erklärt, wie man richtig die Zähne putzt. Und es war immer anders. Also die kamen relativ häufig, so jedes Jahr kamen wir vorbei und es war jedes Mal anders, weil die Zahnwissenschaft anscheinend jede Woche irgendwie neue Dinge sich ausgedacht hat und das ist doch nicht gut, die Methode erst in Kreisbewegungen, dann kam die nächsten Monat auf gar keinen Fall durch die Kreisbewegungen machen. Ihr seid sofort, ab Karis, sofort, ihr seid die nächste Zeit nicht mehr im Leben, niemals Kreisbewegungen machen. Man ist ja auch sehr verwirrt, also man ist ja auch willig, dann als Kind dem zu folgen und zu sagen, ja gut, ich will halt nicht Karies bekommen, ist scheiße, das macht Löcher in meinen Zähnen, das tut Asch weh, ich will einfach richtig meine Zähne putzen und dann ist ja eine gute Motivation eigentlich schon für ein Kind, aber dann sich immer zu widersprechen ist schon ein bisschen blöd. Ja, ist tatsächlich schwierig, aber gab es es bei euch oft, dass irgendwie Erwachsene in die Schule kamen, ausserhalb von Lehrern und gesagt haben, so ein Polizist gekommen und hat gesagt, stellt nichts an, wir kriegen euch. Bei uns kam immer so ein Polizistenbus und dann haben die immer so ein Handspiel, Puppenspiel aufgeführt. Aber es waren echte Polizisten und irgendwann haben alle Schüler so den Respekt für Polizisten verloren, weil wir dachten, ja gut, die stehen halt manchmal an der Straße und halten Autos an oder an, oder sie machen so ein Handspiel-Puppen-Dings-Theater, Kasperle-Theater für Kinder, um denen zu sagen, dass man nicht schnell fahren soll. Aber dafür hattet ihr enormen Respekt vor Handspielpuppen, da ging dann gar nichts mehr, weil ich immer dachte, da steckt wahrscheinlich ein Polizist dahinter, ich sollte jetzt mal lieber keine Scheiße machen. Und wenn der Kasper mich fragt, ob der Wolf hinter ihm steckt, dann sage ich auch ja, weil das ist gefährlich, man muss immer die Wahrheit sagen, Handpuppen. Absolut. Wir hatten übrigens auch mal so einen Kurs, da kamen so Schauspieler bei uns, dann sollten wir irgendwie Respekt lernen und dann sollten wir auch lernen, wie wir uns selber verteidigen und wie wir selber reagieren, wenn wir mal angemacht werden oder so, wenn was passiert mit uns, was nicht passieren sollte, was wir nicht wollen. Und es war wirklich, die Lösung war, man soll die Hand ausstrecken vor ein und sagen, Stopp, nein. Und das soll es gewesen sein. Das kenne ich auch. Also ich meine, das kommt es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut rüber, nur auditiv. Aber ich habe auch mal so eine Ferienbetreuung von Kindern gemacht, die schon ein bisschen älter war, so zehn Jahre oder so. Und die haben auch gesagt, die hatten immer so eine Routine, die sie abfahren sollten, wenn sie gemobbt werden. Und ich kann ja vielleicht mal ein Video von mir machen, und es gibt irgendwo ein Video, wo ich diese Routine mache, weil es ist sehr hüftbetont und sehr sassy, aber der Text lautet es folgendermaßen. Halt, stopp, ich fühle mich gemobbt, mein Niveau, dein Niveau, hallo, Abstand. Und bei mein Niveau, dein Niveau macht man halt so ein mein Niveau hoch, dein Niveau unten, hallo, Abstand. Ich schwöre dir, Wenn du das in der U-Bahn machst, kriegst du einen auf die Fresse.
Ja, wirst du jetzt so zusammengeschlagen, genau.
Wo ich mir auch dachte, die Lehrer, die verarschen
die Kinder doch einfach nur. Als ob irgendwie
Bogdan, der irgendwie das achte Mal die achte
Klasse macht, vor dir steht und dein Pausenbrot
will und du, halt, stopp,
ich fühle mich gebatz einfach
ins Gesicht, damit sie genau wissen, wo sie
hinschlagen sollen. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz vieler Trick von
Lehrern, um uns zu demütigen, um Kinder zu demütigen. Ja, damit du deine Verteidigung aufmachst, damit du mit der Hand in den Handeln. Es ist immer dieses mysteriöse Spektakel, was immer gemacht wird, um dieses Lehrerzimmer. Ich glaube, da passiert nichts anderes, als sich nur Methoden auszudenken, um Kinder zu demütigen. Man hat relativ in der Oberstufe angefangen, die Lehrer cooler zu werden. Ein Lehrer hat uns gesagt, dass er sich, wenn er Deutscharbeiten kontrollieren muss, aus einer fünften oder sechsten Stufe, dass er sich dann immer mit seinen Kumpels trifft und säuft dabei, weil es nichts Lustiges gibt, eine Fünftklässler-Klausel durchzulesen, was ich mir voll vorstellen kann. Das muss total geil sein. Aber tatsächlich, ich erinnere mich noch gut daran, dass tatsächlich in der fünften Klasse oder früher auch Deutschunterricht wesentlich cooler und kreativer war, weil man ja wirklich auch selber Geschichten schreiben musste. Ich weiss gar nicht, warum man das in den hohen Stufen nicht mehr macht, aber irgendwie so, man kriegt so Schlagwörtergeschichten und schreibt dann irgendwie eine Geschichte. Und bei mir war es immer dasselbe. Ich wusste immer, dass diese Klausur kommt mit drei Schlagworten und dann musste man dazu eine Geschichte schreiben.
Und bei mir war es immer selber, ich habe mir im Tag davor eine Folge X-Faktor, das Unfassbare, angeschaut, wo immer so zehnminütige Geschichten mit einem grossen Twist am Ende kamen, habe die einfach auswendig gelernt und habe sie in der Klausur geschrieben, scheisse egal, was die Schlagworte waren, und habe sie einfach im letzten Satz so, und sie war gar nicht tot. und auf ihrem Grab lag eine Streichholzschachtel, ein Pogostick und vier Gramm Zucker. Man wird willkürlich irgendwo runtergebracht. Aber bei mir war es so ähnlich. Ich habe immer diese Gänsehautbücher gelesen, die ja teilweise wirklich auch manchmal blutig waren. Da war ich noch sehr jung und die waren auch, glaube ich, nicht für mein Alter zu dem Zeitpunkt. Da habe ich halt immer, in so einem Jahr Geschichten, ja, und das muss das Wort Rose beinhalten und so, dann habe ich so ganz, ganz furchtbare Gruselgeschichten geschrieben, irgendwie auch mit viel Blut und viel Tod und so. Man muss sich nicht mal vorlesen, die Kinder hatten immer richtig Angst, wenn, oh nein, Stefan muss seine Geschichte vorlesen, die war meistens richtig heftig. Und dann die Lehrerin auch immer, was stimmt denn nicht mit ihm, was ist denn falsch, das ist doch nicht gut. Nein! Du solltest mich niemanden umbringen in deiner Geschichte. Das Thema war doch Liebe. Ich erinnere mich noch genau, wir hatten mal auch Thema Zeitmaschine, ein total geiles Thema. Das stimmt. Mein Bruder hatte mir tatsächlich davor einen Ratschlag gegeben, übrigens derselbe Bruder mit dem Genghis Khan-Ratschlag, mit dem tollen Gag, dass man Oliver Kahn als Gag anürzt. Er fängt an, so eine geile Sidekick-Rolle in diesem Podcast zu übernehmen. Genau, mein Bruder hat mir gesagt, hey, das Wichtigste zum Schreiben von guten Geschichten ist, überleg dir, was alle anderen schreiben und schreib genau das Gegenteil und schreib genau was anderes. Zum Beispiel beim Thema Zeitmaschinen würden alle eine Geschichte schreiben, wie sie ins Mittelalter reisen oder in die Zukunft und fliegende Autos oder in die Antike. Und was habe ich geschrieben? Eine Geschichte, wo jemand einen Tag in die Vergangenheit reist. Und dann sozusagen den Tag nochmal neu erlebt und dann total viel Action. Und dann passiert total viel Action, in meinem Kopf war das alles so ausgespielt. Und dann gab es so eine Verfolgungsjagd, wo irgend so ein Typ, der nicht mal bewaffnet war, hinter dem Protagonisten herrannte. Und ich habe einfach so, weil es in meinem Kopf so aussah, den random Satz geschrieben, er rannte durch die Gasse und links und rechts explodierten die Autos und überall schlugen Schüsse ein. Ohne dass es überhaupt einen Hintergrund gibt, warum das jetzt so sein soll. Und ich weiß, der Lehrer hat einfach ein großes Fragezeichen daneben gemacht, so what? Aber bei mir gehört das einfach dazu, dass wenn eine Verfolgungsjagd geschieht, einfach links und rechts Dinge explodieren, auch wenn es eine Schlittenfahrt war, irgendwie in der Antarktis, egal, es müssen einfach Dinge explodieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei dir auch so war, aber ich hatte immer so das Problem, ich habe immer relativ schnell geschrieben und meistens wollte ich dann Dinge wieder wegmachen, weil dann dachte ich mir ja, das hat gar keinen Sinn, mach's wieder weg. Und dann hat man ja, als Schüler hat man einen Füller und einen Tintenkiller, also zwei Chancen, was richtig hinzuschreiben. Und meistens hat das bei mir nicht gereicht. Und dann habe ich einen Klausel, da mussten wir einen Weg beschreiben. Also einfach nur, ja, da müssen sie nachher geradeaus gehen, dann biegen sie die erste rechts ab und dann wieder sofort links. So, dann habe ich aber mich verschrieben mit dem Tintenkiller. Dann habe ich da so eine Geschichte daraus gemacht, dachte mir, ja komm, du musst das jetzt irgendwie umdrehen. Aber bei Wegbeschreibungen kannst du nicht gut umschreiben. Da bin ich so einen ganz komischen Weg gegangen und da waren auch zwischendurch mal so Sätze drin wie, ja, jetzt gehen Sie rechts, aber halt, das ist der falsche Weg, gehen Sie doch wieder geradeaus. Solche Dinge sind da drin und das war meine schlechteste Note damals bis dahin, das war echt traurig. Aber das konnte ich noch nie sowas.
Ach Gott, sehr schön.
Schulgeschichten, geil.
Ich wusste auch tatsächlich, man wusste ja manchmal so, was eigentlich eine total gute Bestrafung ist,
eigentlich Menschen mit Kreativität zu bestrafen.
Dass er ist, irgendeine Schülerin ist irgendwie der Tintenkiller runtergefallen vom Tisch,
sofort Strafe, ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum das jetzt so schlimm ist,
aber auf jeden Fall sofort Strafe, irgendwie schreib einen Aufsatz, warum dir nicht die Stifte vom Tisch fallen sollen. Und dann hat sie so eine ganz herzzerreissende Geschichte geschrieben, ja, und mein Tintenkiller hat auf dem Blatt des Nachbarns einen Fehler gesehen und er konnte einfach nicht widerstehen, den Fehler zu korrigieren und wollte auf den Tisch des Nachbarn springen und hat es nicht ganz geschafft. Und wir alle in der Klasse so What the fuck, das ist das Beste, was ich je gehört habe, das ist die beste Story ever, das ist so eine gute Idee. Der Tintenkiller hat auf dem Blatt des Nachbarn etwas Rechtsradikales entdeckt und wollte sich daraufhin einfach nur noch umbringen. Ja, genau, aber einfach so eine geile Idee, den Gegenstand zu einer menschlichen Seele einzuhauen.
Das ist eine total gute Idee.
Sollte man machen, auch so das nächste Mal beim Gerichtsverfahren irgendwie.
Warum haben sie keinen Blinker angemacht, als sie um die Ecke gebogen sind und damit ist ein Schaden entstanden.
Einfach zu machen und mein Auto war schon ganz müde und konnte nicht mehr blinken.
Der eine Blinker fiel schon so zu.
Genau. Ja, aber sie dürfen aber nicht mit einem müden Auto Auto fahren, ist ihnen schon klar. Ja, aber der Richter nimmt das dann auch ernst. Wo wir gerade bei Schulzeit waren, die Schulzeit ist ja auch eine wichtige Zeit, in der sich viele Persönlichkeitsmerkmale entwickeln, wie zum Beispiel auch, man erlernt die ersten Hobbys. Viele Leute haben ja heute noch Hobbys aus ihrer Kindheit, haben in der Kindheit angefangen, Fussball zu spielen oder Briefmarken zusammen machen, das heute noch. Und deswegen wollte ich heute einfach mal mit dir ein bisschen über das Thema Hobby reden, weil Podcasten ist ja unser Hobby. Das heißt, wir müssen im Podcast auch über Hobbys reden, weil wir sonst eigentlich keine Hobbys haben. Und ich möchte einfach mal mit einer Frage direkt einfach einsteigen. Da sprichst du für dich. Sind Hobbys der Sinn des Lebens?
Also, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, wir brauchen jetzt mal eine Definition von Hobby.
Das brauchen wir auch dafür.
Um diese Frage zu beantworten, müssen wir erst mal klären, was ist überhaupt ein Hobby?
Ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, etwas, was man kontinuierlich verfolgt.
Ja, ich würde sagen, ein Hobby ist ein kleiner Hobbit.
So.
Wenn das der Gag war,
der eine, den du dazu aufgeschrieben hast,
brech an dieser Stelle ab.
Ja,
also es gibt viele verschiedene Hobbys und also eigentlich Hobby ist das,
was man macht, wenn man einfach nichts zu tun hat, gerade.
Hobby kommt von Hobby-Hobbitek. Hobby kommt von Hobby-Keller, ja. Alles, was man im Hobby-Keller macht, ist Hobby. Hobby ist halt das, was man nicht machen muss, aber trotzdem macht und da Bock drauf hat, irgendwie. Das sind Hobbys. Ist es dein Beruf oder Berufung? Ich finde, was ich beruflich mache, ist im weitesten Sinne auch mein Hobby. Ich beschäftige mich mit Dingen, die mich unterhalten. Das mache ich sehr gerne und darüber hinaus gibt es bei mir nicht viel. Und deswegen ist es mein Hobby, würde ich sagen, auch mein Beruf. Ja, Hobby ist ja, sage ich mal, eine Kategorisierung von Freizeitaktivitäten. Hobby ist ja wie so ein Eisladen, da gibt es ja verschiedene Sorten. Es gibt ja Dinge, die Leute gerne machen, aber die nicht als Hobby angesehen werden.
Also Stalken zum Beispiel würde man jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht als Hobby so definieren.
Klassische Hobbys, Reiten, Lesen, Schwimmen, so ist Klassisches, was man halt so macht und Zeit vertreibt.
Sport, Sport sind klassische Hobbys.
Aber es gibt dann, also was mich interessiert, ist die Frage, was sind deine Hobbys, die Frage.
Weil das ist ja oft so, wenn man irgendwie Leute interviewt und so, ist das oft so die erste Frage, was sind so deine Hobbys, so ein bisschen Einblick ins Privatleben, was macht die Person ausserhalb des Beruflesen, man versucht sich ja schon über die Hobbys eine Person so ein bisschen erschliessen zu können. Sich selber über die Hobbys bewusst zu werden, die man hat, hilft einem auch, seinen Weg in der Welt und seinen Platz in der Welt zu finden.
Und deswegen fand ich es damals super dankbar, dass es immer diese Freundebücher gab, bei uns zumindest, die wir mal rumgereicht haben und wo ich andauernd wöchentlich dazu aufgefordert wurde, meine Hobbys darzulegen und meine Menschen... Hast du so eins noch eigentlich? Ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, ob wir uns vielleicht nicht gegenseitig jetzt ein Freundebuch ausfüllen wollen, quasi hier virtuell. Warte mal, ich habe noch eins, warte, ich hole mal meins. Ich habe das aus meiner Kindheit. Ich komme gleich. Man muss dazu sagen, dass der Florentin nicht, ich hole mal was zu drücken, ich habe keine Lust, dass du erzählst. So, ja, ich habe das tatsächlich noch. Von meinen ganzen alten Freunden früher damals, das war aber wirklich sehr, 1998 ist das Jahr, da war ich sieben Jahre alt. Und da haben wir Hobbys zum Beispiel von Jakob ist Fussball spielen. Hallo, hallo, hallo. Ich bin wieder da, ich habe mir was zu trinken geholt. Ich habe mir was zu trinken geholt. Hallo? Okay, also ich habe mein altes Freundschaftsbuch gefunden. Ich muss sagen, du wohnst in Berlin, du wohnst ja gar nicht mehr da, wo du früher gewohnt hast. Du hast dein Freundschaftsbuch mitgenommen, das sagt ja auch viel über dich aus. Von 1998, da war ich sieben Jahre alt, und die Hobbys hier, also zum Beispiel Jakob hat das Hobby Fussball spielen, Classic, Manuela hat das Hobbys Reiten, Schwimmen und alles, was man noch machen kann, außer Fußball. Also kleiner Gegenentwurf zu Jakob. Antonella mit dem Hobby Alles. Sehr gut. Alex mit dem Hobby Playstation und Skaten. Sehr gut. Sehr cool. Wunderbar. Stefanie, in die ich unsterblich verliebt war. Hobbys Schwimmen und Turnen. Schwierig. Und das war es auch schon. Das waren alle meine Freunde. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich noch, meine Lieblingslehrerin habe ich das auch gegeben, und da gab es nur zwei Seiten, links und rechts, und links konnte man immer so seine Daten reinschreiben, und rechts kamen dann so die persönlichen Sachen, so Hobby oder was man gerne werden möchte, und meine Lehrerin hatte einfach die rechte Seite ein riesiges Foto reingeklebt von Charlie Chaplin und hat einfach alle Fragen überklebt und nicht beantwortet. Wo ich mir dachte, auch, also Frau Meister, das war nix. Aber das war, naja. Ich habe das damals auch meiner Mutter gegeben irgendwie, eine rührende Geschichte, und sie hat bei Mein Schwarm jemand anderen hingeschrieben als mein Vater, deswegen habe ich zu lange Zeit. Oh mein Gott, wie gut ist das denn? Das ist totallich. Mama, ich habe keine Freunde. Willst du mein Freundesbuch schreiben? Ja, gern. Mein Schwarm, Metzger Bayer. Oh. Okay. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Scherz. Ach, musst du mal das da reinschreiben? Schwarm bei euch, das ist ja auch ganz gut. Ja, ich, ich weiß, das war immer so der Moment, wo man erkennt, wer das Freundebuch ernsthaft ausfüllt und wer es mit einem zwinkernden Auge ausfüllt. Ja, apropos zwinkernde Auge, was mich, also was tatsächlich, glaube ich, der erste Gag in meinem Leben war, den ich jemals gehört habe und mich einfach jahrelang noch fasziniert hat, und zwar hat der gute alte Alex geschrieben bei Was ich werden möchte, 16 Jahre hat er geschrieben. Da dachte ich mir schon, nice, gut Mann. Einfach mit dem Medium spielen, bisschen, yeah, guter Mann. Aber der ist cool, er skatet und haut Gags raus. Ja, absolut. Der war der coolste Typ, der war auch älter als ich, der war ein Freund von meinem Bruder tatsächlich und war einer der coolsten Typen, der war einmal im Urlaub. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das so interessant ist, in meine privaten Umfeld reinzugehen, aber ich will jetzt mal ein bisschen, wir reden über Hobbys, wir reden heute über private Dinge, ich will doch mal wissen, wer sind die coolsten Leute, denen du jemals begegnet bist. Ich habe mal gesehen, dass er einen Krankenwagen gefahren hat, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das eher so ein Hobby war oder ob er sich kein anderes Auto leisten konnte oder ob das sein Beruf war. Ich habe immer gesehen, wie er sich hier hängt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das nur ein Hobby war oder ob er das irgendwie langfristige Erlösung war. Ich habe immer gesehen, wie er im Krankenwagen lag, habe ich das verstanden. Ich habe ihn mal im Friedhof gesehen, bei der Beerdigung, aber ich weiß nicht, was der heute so macht. Naja. Mein Hobby ist ja Menschen beobachten. Ja, teilweise gehst du ein bisschen zu weich. Anders gesagt, was sind die schlimmsten Antworten auf die Frage, was ist dein Hobby? Und ich finde, Menschen beobachten ist so ein Ding, wo man immer, wo man so halb poetisch klingt, so ein bisschen, ich bin total der Menschentyp und ich finde, Menschen machen die schönsten Geschichten, bla bla bla. Aber es ist halt auch sau creepy, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gehört. Ich beobachte ja total gern Menschen, ich bin ja so ein Menschenbeobachter. Man hat immer diesen Fernglas-Typ im Kopf, der irgendwie am Fenster den ganzen Tag steht und Leute beobachtet. Das ist echt gruselig. Ja, der Leuten mitten in der Nacht anruft und sagt, euer Fernseher ist noch an. Und dann sagt er, das können sie ja eigentlich gar nicht sehen. Die sollen mal bitte umschalten, weil er würde gerne ProSieben gucken. Wäre auch ganz geil. Ja, sowas zum Beispiel. Ja, Hobbys, aber Menschen beobachten, was auch gruselig ist zum Beispiel, was zu sagen, wie ja, ich lerne den menschlichen Körper kennen oder so. Wo man dann immer denkt, ja, Hobbys der menschliche Körper, ja. Meinen Körper entdecken, sowas ist vielleicht nicht das Beste. Wer sagt das denn? Niemand hat das gesagt. Nur weil dein Onkel das gesagt hat, muss das nicht so allgemein sehen.
Mein Onkel wollte immer meinen Körper kennenlernen.
Ui.
Ups.
Auch man hat immer mal lachen können.
Der ist, als er bei euch vorbeigekommen ist, hatte immer einen Hasen vorbei. Da hat er gesagt,
du kannst den Hasen anfangen und hat immer so einen Zylinder
auf seinen Schoss gesetzt. Komm, ich zeige dir mal einen richtigen Hasen.
Hier, du darfst den Hasen
streicheln, aber der ist immer krank, der spuckt dich vielleicht an. Oh Gott. Ganz kurz, ich sehe schon ein bisschen, es ist ein bisschen schwierig für dich, über deine Hobbys zu reden. Du bist ja auch so ein Typ, der keine Hobbys hat, aber ich möchte mit dir einfach mal einen Hobby-Test machen. Moment mal, was ist dein Hobby? Ich möchte jetzt mit dir, ich habe einen Test gefunden, finde das richtige Hobby für dich. Also wenn du nicht weißt, was dir Spaß macht, was ist tatsächlich das richtige Hobby für dich? Und zwar die Frage, wie lange hast du pro Tag Zeit? Ein bis zwei Stunden, zwei bis drei Stunden, dreissig Minuten oder drei bis vier Stunden? Was war das Erste nochmal? Ein bis zwei Stunden. Ja, sagen wir mal so drei Stunden. Drei Stunden, zwei bis drei. Okay, jetzt die allerschönste Frage, die ich finde, in dem Quiz, das dazu führen soll, was dein Hobby ist. Was machst du besonders gerne? Erstens Sport, zweitens Malen und Zeichnen, drittens Fussball, zweitens Tennis, so Millionen Ausnahmöglichkeiten, wo dein Hobby ausführen kannst.
Drittens, lesen, viertens, singen.
Also was machst du besonders gerne?
Sport, malen, lesen oder singen?
Lesen dann.
Lesen, okay.
Schwachsinn.
Angenommen, ich würde jetzt beide gerne Briefmarken sammeln, wie soll man jetzt darauf kommen?
Spielst du ein Instrument?
Und jetzt finde ich eine der schönsten Antwortmöglichkeiten.
Erstens, ja, es macht mega Spaß. Und zweitens, ja, aber ich möchte aufhören. Ja, aber ich würde diese Fähigkeit gerne verlieren. Ja, aber ich komme nicht von weg. Ich würde gerne aufhören. Was ist dein Ziel in den nächsten drei Jahren? Ich würde langsam von der Gitarre wegkommen, wenn es geht. Was ist das für eine Aussage? Ja, aber ich möchte aufhören. Ich würde wahnsinnig gerne weniger gut Klavier spielen können. Ja, sag mal ja, es macht mir auch Spaß. Ja, es macht mir mega Spaß. Wie oft möchtest du dein Hobby ausüben? Fast jeden Tag, jeden Tag, einmal die Woche oder wenn ich Zeit und Lust habe? Ja, wenn ich Zeit und Lust habe. Ja, ach was. Oh Gott, was ist für eine Scheisse eigentlich, wo, wo du da gelandet hast? Möchtest du professionell dein Hobby ausführen? Ganz kurz. Widerspricht sich vielleicht ein bisschen. Das ist gerade nicht irgendwie wieder so eine Frau, die dir Sex anbietet und der du jetzt irgendwie schreibst. Doch, doch, wir chatten jetzt halt ein paar Wochen tatsächlich. Und die will einfach wissen, was du für Hobbys hast. Ja, okay. Also, möchtest du professionell dein Hobby ausführen?
Auf jeden Fall, nicht unbedingt, nein, oder ja, ein bisschen Hilfe kann nicht schaden.
Wie, ein bisschen Hilfe kann nicht schaden?
Keine Ahnung, das ist einfach so ein allgemeines Statement.
Ja, das würde ich aber gerne nehmen.
Ja, ein bisschen Hilfe kann nicht schaden.
Ist dir oft langweilig?
Ja, ja, ich sitze nur vor dem Computer, ab und zu, oder nein, eigentlich nicht. Ja, ich sitze andauernd vor dieser dämlichen Gitarre, nein, ich habe nicht oft Langeweile. Machst du dein Hobby lieber selbst oder mit Freunden? Beides, immer mit meinen Freunden, selber oder lieber selbst? Ist auch gut. Ich gucke lieber Leuten zu, die mein Hobby ausüben. Es gibt sowohl die Antwortmöglichkeit selbst als auch lieber selbst. Wollen Sie sich auch fragen, was ist denn da los? Aber gut, vielleicht ist es lieber selbst, okay. Und jetzt meine absolute Lieblingsfrage, hast du eine Lieblingseinstellung? Erstens, ich bin Scene oder Szene, zweitens, nee, hab ich nicht, Smiley, drittens, Gothic, viertens, Punk. Also du kannst jetzt auswählen zwischen Nein, Szene, Gothic oder Punk. Was ist denn Szene? Weißt du, du kennst dich da aus, du bist so ein Urban-Typ. Man schreibt es S-C-E-N-E, also Scene, ich bin Scene. Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, was das bedeutet. Nee, mach mal das, mach mal das, nee, ich habe keine... Also eine Lebenseinstellung übrigens. Okay, vorletzte Frage, bist du einsam? Und jetzt die beiden Möglichkeiten, nee, nee, nicht wirklich, ja, aber es stört mich nicht, nein, meine Freunde sind immer dabei. Nicht wirklich. Also nicht nee, nee, nicht wirklich, ich habe mich deutlich festgelegt. Okay, letzte Frage, bist du kreativ, sportlich, schlau oder lustig? Das ist ja scheiße. Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Bist du kreativ oder lustig oder schlau? Schlau schließe ich nochmal, das will ich schon mal ausschliessen, präventiv. Bleibt lustig oder kreativ? Ich würde eher sagen kreativ. Okay, gut, Auswertung. Was ist das perfekte Hobby für Stefan Titzel? Und dein Hobby ist Lesen. Ach, wo du vorhin angegeben hast, du wirst Lesen. Herzlich, herrlich. Also, um nur um das jetzt mal geklärt zu haben, Stefan Titzels Hobby haben wir herausgefunden, es ist tatsächlich Lesen. Man kann nach diesem Test nur lesen. Was war das andere nochmal? Sport, ich glaube Schwimmen. Das auch Schwimmen ständig als das Hobby per se, als das quintessentielle Hobby Schwimmen immer kommt. Das weiß ich auch nicht, wer das wirklich als ein Hobby betrachten würde. Schwierig. Ja okay, jetzt wissen wir mehr über mich. Das machen wir aber nicht mit dir auch nochmal. Das ist ja zeitintensiv. Nee, nee, nee, auf keinen Fall. Ich habe mich tatsächlich auch ein bisschen informiert, was die Hobbys sind, die am besten bei Frauen ankommen, tatsächlich. Du bist ja richtig vorbereitet heute. Ja, natürlich. Du hast ja die Mörder, die Mörder Sachen am Start. Also wenn man seine Hobbys ein bisschen danach auslegen möchte, also wenn dein Hobby das Erkunden des Körpers ist, dann könnten dir vielleicht folgende Hobbys auf diesem Etappenziel helfen. Und zwar die bliebsten Hobbys bei Frauen sind Kochen und Yoga.
Ja, okay.
Hat mir zumindest meine Yoga-Lehrerin gesagt.
Und von daher ... Oh Gott.
Oh Gott.
Und ich muss auch bald los, meine Quiche muss noch in den Ofen.
Von daher müssen wir auch ein bisschen jetzt ranmachen.
Aber eigentlich eine gute Sache. Ich wollte mal ganz kurz eine andere Richtung einschlagen. Also, mir sind Millinger im Gegensatz zu dir die Hörer am Herzen und wir haben letzte Woche ein bisschen Anschluss bekommen bei den, was, wir haben ein paar Dinge wohl nicht richtig gemacht und ich bin da sehr dankbar drüber, über Feedback und habe mich da sehr gefreut, dass uns Leute gesagt haben, macht nie wieder ein Hörspiel, Zitathörer, es hat die Zeit, die ich in einem Stau verbracht habe, potenziert, fand ich ein sehr gutes Zitat. Ja, ich habe auch noch ein Zitat, es war sehr anstrengend, habe ich gehört. Oh Gott, es hat mich wütend gemacht, habe ich auch noch gehört. Mein Handy ist jetzt kaputt, ich habe es gegen die Wand geworfen, solche Sachen. Wie man deswegen wütend werden kann, finde ich auch so gut. Ja, und deswegen habe ich gemerkt, das ist total wichtig, dass wir Leute mal auch was sagen lassen dazu. Deswegen habe ich überlegt, warum schaffen wir uns nicht so ein Prepaid-Handy an, was wir die ganze Zeit ausmachen und wo wir unsere Hörer die Nummer geben und wir bitten darum, dass sie eine Voicemail hinterlassen, wo sie wirklich so Sachen mal sagen, was ihnen gefällt, was ihnen nicht gefällt. einfach weil diese Feedback-Funktion im Internet ist halt wahnsinnig ungefiltert. Dann schreibt man auch sehr viel Scheiss rein und man weiss nicht genau,
Ironie funktioniert auch nicht so wirklich.
Und wenn man so ein Handy hat, wo man wirklich drauf sprechen kann, dann ist die Hemmschwelle grösser. Und deswegen schätze ich mal, ist es ein bisschen gefiltertes und ein bisschen konstruktiver Kritik. Finde ich sehr gut. Ich würde es tatsächlich, glaube ich, eher mit Skype machen, oder? Kann man da auch Voicemails hinterlassen? Ja, dass wir uns einfach einen Account anlegen, das Podcast-UFO, und ihr könnt dann einfach uns adden und dann uns eine Sprachnachricht schicken. Und dann könnt ihr uns mal sagen, was los ist. Ja, die wir aber, wo man sagen muss, die könnt ihr uns schicken, aber die werden auch wahrscheinlich benutzt im On. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und wir werden wahrscheinlich auch jeden Sprachfehler von euch komplett ausreizen, euch fertig machen und jeden kleinsten charakterlichen Makel ausreizen. Genau, wahrscheinlich wird das so sein. Aber wir würden uns sehr überfreuen, finde ich eigentlich eine gute Sache, dann könnt ihr uns nämlich helfen, einfach mal um, wie ich diese Themen wir haben es am Anfang, muss man kurz mal sagen, helfen und Hobbys zurechtgelegt. In meinem Textdokument habe ich nämlich diese Wörter, die Schlagbegriffe ganz gross und fett geschrieben. Da betone ich die auch mal so mit. Mit diesen Dingen, wenn wir das einführen, dann könnt ihr uns helfen, dann könnt ihr uns helfen, damit der Podcast besser wird. Es gibt ja sehr absurde Hobbys und Leidenschaften und es gibt oft Leidenschaften und Hobbys, die andere Leute auch ein bisschen verwirren und in Argwohnen versetzen. Und es gibt ja verschiedene Stufen von Toleranz Hobbys gegenüber, also so, ich kann überhaupt nicht verstehen, wie man das machen kann und wie man den ganzen Tag World of Warcraft zocken kann. Und ich fand es sehr schön, in der Fahrschule wurden uns tatsächlich so Sachen erklärt. Und dann, also das ist ein bisschen der Sinn der Fahrschule. Und dann kam es zum Beispiel auch zum Thema Bahnüberfahrt, also Bahnübergang. Also man fährt mit einem Auto, einem Wegbahn, mit motorisierten Vehikel über einen Bahnübergang. Und dann gab es gewisse Dinge, die man dabei beachten muss. Und dann gab es einen Punkt, wenn man eine, und dann kam irgendein technischer Ausdruck, eine WCA-Antenne hat, die länger als drei Meter ist auf seinem Auto, muss man aufpassen, dass man da nicht an die Stromableitung kommt, sonst geht alles kaputt. Und dann kam die berechtigte Frage auf, ja, aber wer hat denn so ein komisches Superfunkgerät, Radio-Ding? Und dann der Fahrlehrer einfach ganz trocken, ja, manche Leute mögen das. Und das war dann einfach die Erklärung, so manche Leute mögen das, mit einer vier Meter langen Antenne auf ihrem Auto rumzufahren, um irgendwie den taiwanesischen Flugfunk abzugreifen. Einfach das war für die Erklärung, ja, manche Leute mögen das. So stand das auch im Lehrbuch drinnen auf die berechtigte Frage, warum zur Hölle sollte irgendjemand das haben. Ja, manche Leute mögen das. Manche machen das so. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was manche Leute machen. Ja, manche Leute machen das so. Fahrschule ist total geil, wir hatten nämlich auch beim Bahnübergang war nämlich auch diese, da habe ich mal,, also bei der Antwort habe ich dann gedacht, okay, alles was man jetzt sagt, ist mir scheißegal, das werde ich niemals verstehen, einfach auswendig lernen für die Theorieprüfung, weil, ich darf niemals mit Kohlensäure trinken. Oh Gott. Es ist nämlich so, wenn man über eine Bahn, das ist wirklich eine Frage, wenn man über eine Bahnüberquerung fährt, muss man, während man auf den Schienen ist, muss man nach links und rechts gucken. Also wenn du in den Schranken hoch sind und du fährst, du bist auf den Schienen, musst du nach links und rechts gucken. Wo ich mir denke, ja, was bringt das, da muss man das auch wirklich in der Prüfung auch machen, sonst fällst du durch. Wenn du auf einem Bahnübergang stehst, musst du links und rechts gucken, ob mit 300 kmh ein Zug in die reinfährt oder nicht. Das ist so das Ding, was du dann machen musst. Das ist wirklich interessant. Ja, muss man, ja. Ich weiß, ich habe die Prüfung auch gemacht. Es ist eher bescheuert. Ja, okay. Ja, sorry. Ich habe übrigens meine Prüfung damals mit Ansage und genau zehn Fehlerpunkten bestanden. Man darf ja nur zehn Fehlerpunkte haben, an denen ich bestanden. Aber auch nur, weil ich wusste eine Frage nicht und ich wusste genau, okay, du hast zehn Fehlerpunkte, schon mal sicher. Also eine von diesen Fragen musst du richtig beantworten. Dann habe ich nicht gewusst und habe ich links neben mir auf dem Bildschirm geguckt und da kam genau die Frage, was sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, weil es tausende Fragen gibt, die theoretisch anders formuliert teilweise noch ein bisschen sind und die halt in so einem Zufallslogarithmus ausgewählt werden. Und dass der links neben mir die gleiche Frage bekommt, ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich. Dass er die auch noch zum gleichen Moment bekommt, während ich die auch beantworte, ist mega unwahrscheinlich. Und dann kam genau die Frage und er die sicher beet, und da habe ich gedacht, gut, wenn er das so sicher beantwortet hat, dann wird es doch richtig sein. Da habe ich es gemacht, und das war richtig. Mit zehn Minuten bestanden. Echt Glück. Das ist echt Glück, auch ein gutes Thema, wenn ich eine Folge mache. Aber Fahrschule ist da, vielleicht machen wir noch mal eine eigene Folge über Fahrschule, weil das ist echt ein ergebliches Thema, und wir hatten auch so einen Nachwuchsfahrlehrer, weil Fahrlehrer sind ja wirklich die abgefucktesten, zynischsten Menschen der Welt. So coole Menschen. Also wirklich die coolsten und die einfach abgeschlossen haben mit dem Leben, die wissen, ich fahre jetzt einfach noch mit 20 Jahren mit Minderjährigen im Auto durch die Gegend und das war's dann und dann lege ich mich hin. Und da war dann aber, wir hatten dann auch einen, der manchmal die Theorie gemacht hat, der total jung und motiviert war und der stand dann vor so einer Projektion von 30 verschiedenen Verkehrsschildern und wollte dann so ein bisschen die Gruppe mit involvieren, hat immer gesagt so,
hey, was glaubt ihr denn, wofür ist denn dieses Verkehrsschild da? Und das war jetzt so ein
durchgestrichenes Pferd. Niemand meldet sich, habt ihr nicht irgendeine Idee? Und niemand hatte halt
Bock, kleiner Tipp, es hat was mit Pferden zu tun. Und da hatte ich irgendwie, ja, Pferde verboten, Ja, richtig, genau, was könnte denn das hier bedeuten? So ein Hund durchgestrichen und alle, oh Gott, das wird eine lange Nacht einfach. Das wird einfach ewig dauern, weil wenn sich einfach niemand dazu herablässt, mit ihm mitzuarbeiten, dann war es das halt einfach, weil er hat es auch nicht gesagt irgendwie. Das war immer dasselbe, irgendwie so ein 100 durchgestrichen. Manche Dinge sind total offensichtlich,
manche Dinge sind super schwer, wie viel Liter
Öl oder wie viel
Wasser braucht man, um einen Tropfen Öl
zu verdünnen und sowas. Solche Fragen kommen dann
da, die so neben so Fragen wie, ja, was
bedeutet dieses durchgestrichene Känguru?
Das sind halt so Dinge.
Aber, warte mal,
haben wir jetzt noch viel Zeit eigentlich? Ne, haben wir
nicht mehr. Wollen wir noch eine Rubrik, eine Rubrik sollten wir noch unterbringen vielleicht heute, oder? Ja klar, komm, was soll's. Welche machen wir denn? Ich finde, eine, die uns auch gesagt haben, die passt ja nur heute, oder? Ja okay, dann machen wir heute unsere neue Rubrik. Wawa wawa wawa wawa wawa wawa wawa wawa dingelililililing. Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island. In unserer Rubrik Topical Island werden wir immer ein aktuelles Thema aus den Medien aufgreifen und humoristisch keck aufgearbeitet, euch zu serbieren. Und heute geht es, wie könnte es anders sein, um den Streik der Deutschen Bahn. Es geht um Berufe, bei denen Streiken absolut keinen Sinn ergibt. und ich hätte mir drei Dinge ausgedacht, weil ich dachte, das machen wir so. Unser Ding ist Zahl drei. Hast du auch drei Dinge? Ja, also die Bahn streicht ja gerade, vielleicht muss man den Zuschauer auch ein bisschen ins Boot holen. Die Bahn streicht ja gerade und alle regen sich auf. Der hält euch für bescheuert und dumm. Viele Leute haben Angst, dass andere Berufsgruppen auch noch anfangen zu streiken, die Kitas streiken. Aber die Frage ist, bei welcher Berufsgruppe würde es überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen und welche Berufsgruppe kann überhaupt keinen Druck auswirken auf die Öffentlichkeit, wenn sie anfangen würde zu streiken, wie zum Beispiel?
Soll ich mit Nummer drei anfangen? Bei mir ist, ich habe mir überlegt, das ist ein zweigeteilter Platz, weil es auch etwa der gleiche Beruf ist, das sind zum einen Eisverkäufer im Kino, die am Anfang immer rauskommen und Eis verkaufen wollen, wo ich sehr selten jemanden sehe, der was kauft. Es ist auch Public Shaming, die Aufmerksamkeit ist immer auf den Eingriffen, der so halb die Hand hochrippt. Der eine Fette. Man sitzt dann nach 30, die 30 Minuten sitzt man da schon und will endlich, dass die Werbung jetzt weg ist und der Film kommt, da kommt der Eisverkäufer und denkt, ja, jetzt geh wieder, niemand will ein Eis und dann kommt dann der eine Dicke aus der letzten Reihe und der Eisverkäufer muss die ganzen Treppen hochgehen und muss dann natürlich das Eis haben, was er dann nicht hat, dann muss er nochmal rausgehen und wieder reinkommen, damit er das eine Eis bekommt, was er will und dann hat er das nicht passend, dann muss er ganz viel Kleingeld rausgeben und so ein Schwachsinn. Und alle hassen das. Meistens gibt es immer diesen Dick noch nicht und Eiswürger vergehen einfach wieder. Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn die streiken würden, würde niemanden jucken. Das stimmt. Ohne Stimme. Gleicher Atemzug, wir Verkäufer im Stadion, immer bei so Großveranstaltungen, sind meistens schwarze Mitbürger, die diese Bierfässer auf dem Rücken haben, mit diesen Bierdingern. Also wenn die jetzt nicht da sind, dann gehen die halt zum Wiesstand halt. Ja, verstehe schon. Tatsächlich geht meine Platzreihe in eine sehr ähnliche Richtung, und zwar Grillwalker. Wenn Grillwalker protestieren würde, wird wahrscheinlich sehr lustig aussehen, wenn die irgendwie eine Demonstration machen. Was ist ein Grillwalker? Grillwalker. Kennst du die nicht? Nein, was ist das? Das sind so Leute, die zum Beispiel in Berlin an Alexanderplatz durch die Gegend laufen, die so einen Propangastank auf dem Rücken haken und vor sich so einen Grill, wie so einen Bauchladen, umgesteilt und darauf Bratwürste grillen und dann Bratwürste verkaufen. Ach so, ja, das habe ich ja schon mal gesehen, aber ich kenne die Grillwalker heisst das. Deswegen ist das auch gruselig,, wie ein Grillwalker. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Auf jeden Fall heißen die Grillwalker und wenn die produzieren würden,
wirst du wahrscheinlich auch niemanden aufreiten.
Platz zwei.
Nee, das ist doch guter Platz, aber ich kann das nicht.
Platz zwei ist bei mir Buchläden.
Also wenn Buchläden in der Innenstadt einfach dicht machen würden,
das würde niemanden interessieren.
Gut, dann kaufe ich halt bei Amazon, dann ist es auch schon morgen da.
Was wollt ihr denn machen, wenn ihr bei uns keine Bücher mehr kauft? Amazon? Ah ja, ja, stimmt. Okay, okay, gut. Ich verstehe dich. Genau, es dürfen generell keine Leute streiken, deren Alternative besser ist als sie selbst. Das stimmt. Das war auch so ein bisschen meine Gedanken, als ich überlegte, was man da aufschreiben kann. Das war genau das. Mein Platz Nummer zwei, Blogger. Ich glaube, wenn Blogger streiken würden, wäre es auch einfach scheißegal. Ich schreibe keinen einzigen Blog-Eintrag mehr über überflüssige Konsumgüter und wie Frauen in den Medien unterdrückt werden, bis wir mehr Gehalt bekommen. Ich glaube, ich würde niemand interessieren. Die Welt ohne Blogs würde niemandem fehlen. Ja, dann habe ich auch noch, ich habe das ja auch gar nicht numeriert eigentlich, Platz 1 ist vielleicht auch nicht besser als, vielleicht war Platz 2
besser als der jetzt kommt.
Als kleiner Teaser.
Leute von einer
Fastfood-Kette, wenn jetzt plötzlich
alle McDonalds wieder weiter streiken,
scheißegal, dann geht man einfach zu McDonalds
oder zu Burger King oder zu Subway
oder zu KFC, ist scheißegal.
Das ist Dinge, genau wie, wenn Airbus streichen würde, ja, dann kaufen die Airlines halt bei Boeing. So, das sind diese Dinge, wo es einfach eine Parallele geht, die einfach genau gleich ist, die gleiche Service anbietet, nicht viel schlechter. Das stimmt, guter Punkt, ja. Bei mir, also ich habe jetzt noch zwei tatsächlich, die in eine ähnliche Richtung geben, und zwar einmal der Typ, der die Sticker auf Obst klebt, der einfach sagt, dann esst euer Obst eben ohne Sticker. Viel Spaß, mal schauen, wie lange ihr das durchhaltet. Wird wahrscheinlich auch relativ unerfolgreicher Streik werden. Und dann habe ich noch die Leute, die mit einem Metalldetektor über den Strand laufen. Ich glaube, wenn die streiken würden, wäre jetzt auch nicht so furchtbar. Ich glaube, da käme man auch ganz gut durch. Ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich auch einige Berufsgruppen, die einfach schon seit Jahrzehnten streiken, dass einfach nur niemandem aufgefallen ist und man dadurch einfach gemerkt hat, dass die Berufsgruppe obsolet ist. Einfach, ja, irgendwie so Kerzenhersteller oder sie noch Kerzen von Hand machen, ging in Streik irgendwie 1995, seitdem einfach verschollen. Genau wie bei Jahrmärkten bei der Kirche,, es frage ich mich auch immer, ob man da jetzt, also es ist relativ eindeutig, wer da die Hosen hat, nämlich die von dem grossen Riesenrad mit dem geilen Fahrgeschäft. Und also wer zur Hölle braucht dann zum Beispiel die Entenangler oder so, da gibt es ja Liebhaber. Aber wenn die jetzt streiken würden, die Entenangler, Vereinigung Deutschland, dann wäre es mir egal persönlich. Ja, oder diese Greifarmgeräte, wo man so ein Kuscheltier rausholen kann, wenn die fehlen würden. Ja, genau. Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben die immer so Liebhabergruppen, wo ein Streik dann doch relativ sehr viel vor ist. Das weiß man ja nicht. Ich habe außerdem noch den gesamten Bereich Strassenkünstler, also diese Leute, die in der Fußgängerzone so ganz stillstehen wie eine Statue. Ich glaube, die könnten relativ wenig Druck auf die Bevölkerung ausüben, wenn die streiken würden.
Ich glaube, das hält sich noch stark in Grenzen, das Schadenspotenzial von den Leuten.
Das stimmt.
Oder würden sich dann so Kreise bilden.
Genau. Wir wissen nicht, was wir anschauen sollen.
Jetzt müssen wir echte Statuen anschauen.
Oh nein! Und wo kriege ich jetzt eine lustige Karikatur von mir und Matt Damon her?
Ich würde gerne meinen Namen...
Ich habe gerade das Bedürfnis, meinen Namen
auf einem Reiskorn zu haben.
Wo kriegt das jetzt her?
Wo?
Genau, ja.
Das ist auch geil.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was Leute,
die diese, ihr Namen auf einem Reiskorn
Schilder, Stände haben,
was sie zum Beispiel bei der Krankenkasse angeben
als ihren Beruf.
Oder kann man das auswählen? Ja, guter Punkt, ja? Kann man das auswählen, die Namen auf einem Reisstand? Aber das Problem, die würden das Formular so klein ausfüllen, das könnte man gar nicht verarbeiten. Das ist halt ein bisschen problematisch. Deswegen sind die steuerlich, glaube ich, ganz gut raus. Das sind auch die einzigen, die ihr Name auf einem Reiskorn-Stand-Inhaber in diese kleine Spalte bekommen. Wahrscheinlich sind diese Stände auch gar nicht für uns gedacht, sondern für Mäuse oder so. Die sind wahrscheinlich auch ganz winzige Stände, wo alles ganz klein ist. Und die Mäuse benutzen das ganz normal für ihre Haustür. Ich dachte mir auch, was ist, wenn Tiere streiken? Möwen zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, wenn Möwen streiken würden, wäre auch nicht so schlimm. Ja, oder ähm... Komm schon, Gehirn, lass mich nicht im Stich.
Oder zum Beispiel Spam-Mail-Schreiber, so diese Trading-Angebotsleute.
Doch, nein, doch.
Ich glaube, da würde ich sehr vermissen. Meinst du, das würde fehlen?
Das würde ich arg vermissen.
Ja.
Wir haben noch eine Rubrik am Stich.
Das sind diese Rubrikkinder, die immer so in ihrer Schublade hängen und sich von Rubrik zu Rubrik hangeln. Aber das müsste mir ja nicht sein, oder? Ich wollte noch sagen, Sonntag ist Muttertag. Sonntag ist Muttertag, so als Service. Und hast du da jetzt irgendwelche One-Liner, die du nicht in die Sendung bekommen hast, die du jetzt fetzig raushaust? Nö, ich wollte einfach nur Sonntag ist Muttertag, wollte ich auch mal sagen, so als Service. Wobei wir diese Sendung wahrscheinlich auch nicht vor Sonntag raushauen können. Also ist diese Sendung, diese Info auch einfach völlig unnötig.
Ich schenke meiner Mutter dasselbe wie jedes Jahr einen grossen Packung.
Eine Autogrammkarte von dir selbst.
Genau, ja.
Ein Autogramm von ihr.
Ich will ein Autogramm von ihr zum Muttertag.
Ne, ein Kumpel von mir hat tatsächlich bei Go Butler, der ist nicht, Muttertag ist ja
auf Mallorca, wenn man das halt so macht. Oh fuck, warte mal, sorry, ganz kurz, wir haben die Rubrik nicht beendet. Doch, das können wir einfach reinschneiden. Topical Island. Na, weil die Musik es die ganze Zeit lief. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Man muss Rubriken auch wieder ordnungsgemäß zumachen, sonst funktioniert das nicht. Sonst schwirren sie einem noch rum und man kommt aus diesem Schublad nicht mehr raus. Ja, der ist, hat er die Frage, dass er die Bibel bestellt. Ja, ja, fick dich. Ich habe auch mal Shakespeare zitiert und habe dann nicht Zitat Ende gesagt und seitdem denken alle Leute, alles was ich sage, hätte Shakespeare gesagt. Nehme ich zurück, stimmt nicht. Guter Gag, guter Gag, damit könne man auch mal gut eine Folge beenden. Ich bin relativ zufrieden. Ich hoffe, die Folge hat euch besser gefallen als die letzte Folge, für die ich mich nochmal im Namen der ganzen Redaktion entschuldigen möchte. Ja, tut mir leid. Aber wir müssen auch nach vorne gucken. Es ist immer so ein Auf und Ab und Hoch und Runter. Die nächste Folge ist bestimmt... Nächste Woche hat Florentin noch keinen Delay mehr, den habe ich heute immer, ich habe nie gehört, wenn er was gesagt hat,
weil er immer irgendwie in mich reingeredet hat, weil er
einen 30-Minuten-Delay hat. Ist nicht schlimm,
nächste Woche hat er Breitband-Internet
von 50.000 Bit, sagen wir mal, oder?
Mindestens. Ja, ja, ja.
Bis dahin wünschen wir euch viel Spaß, viel Spaß
bei unseren Hobbys, schreibt uns doch einfach mal, was habt ihr denn
so für Hobbys? Hashtag Hobby
Ja, und der Skype,
unser Skype-Account natürlich, der ist ab dieser Woche
neu, da sollt ihr Voicemails draufschreiben.
Bitte gebt euch Mühe, bitte
putzt euch vorher nochmal die Zehn.
Genau. Macht's gut, bis zum
nächsten Mal, bis dahin, haut rein. Tschüss.
Wir heben ab, macht's gut.